en 2005 le futuriste rekers wet publie
un livre intitulé la singularité est
proche
depuis le terme singularité s'est
entouré de mysticisme avec un penchant
catastrophiste à la skynet et les robots
humanoïdes à la terminator qui vous
détruire le monde ou un penchant
utopistes qui prétend que tous nos
problèmes seront résolus du jour au
lendemain de la faim dans le monde à
l'éradication des maladies en passant
par le contrôle des changements
climatiques et la gestion optimisée et
raisonnée des ressources sans compter
l'augmentation des facultés humaines
voire peut-être les fantasmes
d'immortalité
malheureusement ce genre de discussion a
tendance à éveiller l'hooliganisme en
nous si bien que quand on parle de
singularité peu importe ce qu'on en dit
il y aura des gens et même beaucoup de
gens qui vont tourner en dérision tout
ce qu'on dit oui je te vois toi qui a
commencé à écrire un commentaire qui se
moque d'une caricature de la vie que je
n'ai pas encore exprimé du coup avant de
nous emballer à imaginer des futurs
exotiques utopiste ou catastrophiste je
vous invite à d'abord nous arrêter sur
l'incroyable succession de prédiction
raté des plus grands intellectuels en
vous narrant une trêve histoire du passé
du futurisme l'histoire moderne de
l'intelligence artificielle des buts
certainement avec l'article de 1950
d'alan turing dont on a déjà parlé dans
les épisodes 2 à 7
les années 50 puis 60 connu ensuite une
grande cas de d'optimisme et
enthousiasme avec des chercheurs comme
marvin minsky john mccarthy et claude
shannon ou encore noam chomsky et right
woman of a down à minsk et en
particulier déclara en 1967 la chose
suivante
d'ici trois à huit ans on aura une
machine avec une intelligence général
d'un humain moyen
cependant à la fin des années 60 et au
début des années 70 les progrès ralentir
de pessimisme augmentant les
investissements diminuaient voilà qui
était de mauvaise augure pour la
recherche one piece est en effet pendant
les années 70 l'euphorie pour
l'intelligence artificielle fut tourné
en dérision en 1974 le mathématicien
lykke li randy un rapport sur l'état de
l'intelligence artificielle au royaume
uni
n'hésita pas à conclure que le robot à
tout faire est un mirage ce fut le
premier hiver de lire ou et à windsor
[Musique]
puis tout à coup au début des années 80
trois évènements relancer l enthousiasme
pour l'ia en 1981 le gouvernement
japonais investis 850 millions de
dollars dans le domaine ce qui motive à
d'autres gouvernements à travers le
monde à faire de même qui plus est
l'algorithme de rétro propagation fut
découvert aujourd'hui cet algorithme est
le fondement des réseaux de neurones
artificiels dont on reparlera plus tard
dans cette série mais surtout les
chercheurs en ils abandonnèrent la quête
d'une intelligence général au profit de
systèmes experts ou exploite six thèmes
ce dans des domaines en particulier
saisir exploitèrent la connaissance des
experts pour résoudre des problèmes
habituellement réservé à ces experts
misent en 1984 mills qui cette fois
prudents annonça que l'enthousiasmé
était alors démesurée et qu'il craignait
un retour d'un hiver de l'ia
[Musique]
ensco et l'hiver arrive à trois ans plus
tard en 1987
encore une fois les investissements
s'effondrèrent il devint académiquement
tabou de s'intéresser à l'idée même
d'intelligence artificielle par les 10
ha
c'était se couvrir de ridicule ainsi at
helix saclay 2017 cédric villani a
raconté ce qui suit au hasard des études
a fait que je me suis retrouvé
mathématicien des sujets très solide
bien loin de l'image de flou qu'avait
l'intelligence artificielle à cette
époque quand l'un de mes collègues s'est
lancé là dedans dans l'intelligence
artificielle dans les années 2000 je dis
ce que tu sûr de ce que tu fais c'est un
sujet qui n'a pas abouti à grand chose
pour l'instant et comme je me trompe et
tout le monde se tromper personne
n'avait anticipé que ça reviendrait sur
le devant de la scène avec tant de force
mieux encore en 2011 quand je me suis
mis à lire sur les réseaux de neurones
pour la première fois j'ai conclu que
c'était vraiment de la grosse merde et
que ça n'aurait aucune chance de faire
des trucs incroyables pour le lait de
2011 la recherche en y a été vouée à
l'échec
sauf que comme on l'a vu dans le premier
épisode de cette série depuis 2012 l'ia
n'a cessé d'enchaîner les succès
époustouflant au point de devenir
incontournable aujourd'hui tout le monde
parle de liens l'ia est re devenu un
trending topic
à tel point qu en croire certains il
n'est plus si déraisonnable de penser
qu'une intelligence artificielle de
niveau humain pourrait voir le jour
d'ici disons quelques décennies si je
vous raconte tout cela c'est pour
insister sur la difficulté à prédire le
futur de la recherche en ya à travers
les décennies
il ya eu beaucoup d'optimisme et de
pessimisme excessive la prévision est
difficile surtout lorsqu'elle concerne
le futur dit l'adage et en particulier
ces dernières années je n'ai cessé de
pêcher par et cynisme entre les réseaux
de neurones
la construction de la sémantique la
génération d'image réaliste je n'ai
cessé d'être stupéfait par les progrès
désir
mais de façon étonnante malgré tous ces
va et vient de l'optimisme en liga il se
dessine néanmoins une tendance claire et
nette
les progrès de lier à semble inarrêtable
mais surtout il semble progresser à un
rythme exponentiel et ça de nombreuses
académique le remarquer encore et encore
moore par exemple a énoncé sa fameuse
loi de moore qui dit en gros que les
puissances de calcul double tous les
deux ans ou encore le géant des matches
john von neumann aurait affirmé dans les
années 50 que la loi de progrès
accélérés des technologies donnent
l'impression d'approcher une sorte de
singularité fondamental dans l'histoire
de notre espèce
au delà de laquelle les modes de vie des
humains tels que nous les connaissons ne
pourrons pas continuer erving gaudelus
parle d'explosion de l'intelligence
tandis que bernard winch au prix en 1993
la terminologie de singularité
technologique de bonne manne qui fut
ensuite popularisé notamment dans le
livre la singularité est proche de
rikers wade dans son livre knicks boston
va même jusqu à formaliser
mathématiquement lille et intuitif de
loi no mal on peut ainsi considérer que
l'intelligence artificielle a intenté
est une certaine quantité y doter ce que
sous-entend von neumann c'est que plus
il y doter est élevé plus la vitesse à
laquelle l'intelligence progress est
élevé si on suppose en particulier que
la progression de l'ia est
proportionnelle à son niveau n'obtient
alors l'équation dei sur d'été est égal
à alpha x y doter dont la solution est
une fonction exponentielle idothea est
égal à ces foires puissance al fath et
alors normalement tout ça ça devrait
vous rappeler des souvenirs de lycée
mais je suis à peu près sûr que vous ne
vous rendez pas vraiment compte de ce
que ça signifie vraiment une progression
exponentielle
c'est très très très rapide je pourrais
longuement disserté dessus sans réussir
à vous faire sentir la folie de la
croissance exponentielle mais à titre
d'exemple quand on plie une feuille sur
elle-même double son épaisseur
si on répète cela l'épaisseur de la
feuille augmentera alors un rythme
exponentiel et ce qu'ils font c'est en
partant d'une épaisseur un film suffira
de pied la feuille 42 fois pour que son
épaisseur face la distance terre-lune
c'est complètement fou d'ailleurs je
vous invite à dire à voix haute la
réponse que votre intuition fournirait à
la question suivante combien de fois
faut-il plier l'affairé pour que son
épaisseur face la largeur de l'univers
option
combien de fois d'après vous mille fois
un million 1 milliard petit indice pour
vous aider l'univers observable est
environ un milliard de milliards de fois
plus grand que la distance terre-lune
bref tout ça pour dire que la croissance
exponentielle anticipé par von neumann
risque d'être fulgurante
même si elle semble encore gérable
aujourd'hui risque de complètement nous
stupéfait faire d'ici quelques décennies
et si on n'y est pas préparé on risque
fort de ne pas comprendre ce qui nous
arrive et on n'y est pas préparé
mais il ya peut-être encore plus
surprenant il se pourrait que la vitesse
de progrès des technologies soient
encore plus spectaculaire qu'une
croissance exponentielle oui parce qu'on
pourrait imaginer qu'une petite
amélioration intellectuelle des machines
intelligentes puisse conduire non pas un
petit incrément du rythme de leur
progression mais à un gros un crime en
la vitesse de kova désir autrement dit
au lieu d'avoir des surdités est égal à
alpap wahid haute et on pourrait
imaginer avoir des histoires d'été est
égal à al x x ecaré de thé et d'ailleurs
cette étrange postulat a justement été
suggéré il ya quelques jours également
par open l'un des centres de recherche à
la pointe de la recherche en y a or une
telle équation différentielle à pour
solution est doté est égal à 1 / c -
alpha de thé autrement dit cette
solution divergent au bout d'un temps
finis tes gars là c'est sur alpha ainsi
si l'on en croit cette équation
on pourrait avoir une singularité
mathématiques en temps fini
alors bien sûr il ya beaucoup de bémols
à mettre à une telle analyse pour
commencer bien sûr le concept
d'intelligence est ici très mal définis
tout ce que je viens de raconter ici
n'est nécessairement qu'une métaphore
impossible à formaliser rigoureusement
mais ce n'est pas l'exactitude de
largement qui emporte tous les modèles
sont faux ce qui importe vraiment c'est
le constat de l'accélération des progrès
technologiques qui se justifie par une
observation très simple plus on
progresse plus où me construis d'outils
performants et plus ces outils nous
permettent de progresser vite et quand
on observe n'importe quels indicateurs
économiques
force est de constater que ce progrès a
tendance à fournir des courbe
exponentielle
je vous invite à écouter ce court
extrait d'un tête stocks donnés par
l'économiste andrew mcafee
eric
[Musique]
autre bémol une telle singularité tout
comme la croissance exponentielle
d'ailleurs violerait évidemment les lois
de la physique du coup on doit plutôt
s'attendre à ce que les programmes
atteignent et tout à coup un plateau au
moment où l'intelligence des machines
atteindra ses limites en ressources
naturelles
cependant sachant que notre univers a
réussi à concevoir et à héberger des
intelligences de niveau humain dans une
boîte crânienne à la suite d'une
évolution darwinienne dont
l'optimisation de l'intelligence n'était
pas le but
il est difficile d'imaginer qu'une ia
qui atteindra les limites physiques ne
soit pas très très très largement
supérieur à l'humain en tous points y
compris en terme de gestion optimale de
la consommation d'énergie bon je vous ai
présenté ici pas mal d'arguments
théorique et c'est difficile à avoir
pleinement confiance en ses arguments du
coup on peut essayer de se tourner vers
autre chose par exemple l'avis des
experts en 2012 selon des sondages sur
500 chercheurs lors de conférences en
devenir
la moitié des experts ayant répondu
attribué une probabilité d'au moins 10%
au fait qu'une ia d'intelligence général
supérieur en tout point à l'humain bois
le jour avant 2022 cette majorité des
experts paris au moins 50% de chances de
voir une ya deux niveaux humain avant
2040 et 90% avant 2075 plus récemment
cependant en 2015 selon un sondage sur
352 chercheurs les chercheurs prédisent
en moyenne l'émergence d'une île à deux
niveaux humain pour 2065 mais on peut
voir sur le grave qu'il y a de grandes
variations entre les différents
chercheurs de façon étonnante ces
variations ne semble pas dépendre de l'
expertise ou de la séniorité des
chercheurs sondés mais elles sont
fortement influencées par l'origine
géographique des chercheurs
la singularité semble beaucoup plus
proche selon les asiatiques que selon
les américains
alors avant de sauter au plafond à dire
que les experts sont débiles je vous
rappelle qu'on parle là d'un problème
d'un niveau technique très élevé et que
votre avis a peu de chances d'être plus
pertinent que celui des experts et il
est bien conscience de l'étendue de
votre ignorance
ceci étant dit il faut aussi souligner
que les experts sont très loin d'être
infaillible dans le sondage de 2015 ils
ont prédit qu'il faudrait encore 12 ans
pour surpasser l'homme au jeu de go
alors que alpha go a battu li shi dole
en mars 2016 qui plus est on peut
souligner un important biais de
sélection puisque seuls les experts qui
ont pris le temps de répondre au sondage
nous ont dit ce qu'ils pensaient enfin
ce qu'on voit très bien sur cette courbe
et qui est beaucoup de disparités dans
les prédictions d'un chercheur à l'autre
plus étonnant encore même la vie médian
fluctuent énormément sur ce graphe il ya
par exemple 40 avis qui ont été
sélectionnés aléatoirement
vous voyez qu'entre la vie médian il
suit il juste à gauche et suis juste à
droite prédictions qui correspond à une
probabilité de 50% pour l'émergence
d'une intelligence artificielle de
niveau humain varie facilement de plus
ou moins 10 voire 20 ans bref prédire le
futur c'est pas facile alors perso j'ai
été étonné par ces chiffres
non pas parce qu ils contruisent mon
intuition en fait pour tout vous dire je
suis surtout surpris à quel point les
chiffres de l'expert médian sont
étonnamment conforme à mes propres
croyances bayésienne typiquement je
parierais bien un contre un pour que
l'ia sera en tout point supérieur à
l'humain disons avant 2045
et j'ai pas franchement confiance en ma
prédiction si ces chiffres m'ont
beaucoup surpris c'est surtout parce que
quand on parle à des chercheurs en ia ou
quand on écoute des interventions de
chercheurs en ni à la radio ou à la télé
ou en conférence ceux ci ont tendance à
laisser penser que lié à deux niveaux
humain c'est pas pour demain ni pour
dans 20 ans ni ponant 30 ans ni pour
dans 50 ans parfois mais à bien
réfléchir ce n'est peut-être pas si
étonnant comme le suggère nilis nilsson
les chercheurs en ia subissent un espèce
de biais de respectabilité quand il
parle en public
oui parce que l'histoire de l'île et
notamment ses deux hivers glaciaux des
années 70 et 80 nous invite à faire
preuve de prudence quand on parle en
public parce qu annoncé des trucs
spectaculaire qui n'ont pas lieu
ça la fout mal alors que découvrir des
trucs spectaculaire sans les avoir
annoncé ça n'a aucun coup sûr notre
crédibilité et du coup un chercheur est
mieux vu quand il démystifie les
avancées en n'y a que quand il prédit
d'autres avancées spectaculaires
en bref les incentives de fond que les
chercheurs pour intérêt à se montrer
bien plus prudent que ce que leur
intuition pourrait suggérer et c'est
sans doute pour cela que même si
beaucoup le prince avec une crédence non
négligeable personne n'ose dire que l'ia
pourrait déjà être en tout point
supérieure à l'homme dès 2050
je vous renvoie notamment vers le
dernier axe hommes comme un fait avec
monsieur fillon parle de ce biais bref
il ya beaucoup de bémols à mettre à
notre analyse
néanmoins malgré toutes les difficultés
que posent les prédictions sur le futur
de la recherche en iran il en ressort
toutefois un étonnant consensus il
semble bien qu'il y ait au moins 75% des
chercheurs du domaine
qui pense que l'intelligence en tout
point supérieure à l'homme verra le jour
très probablement dans le siècle à venir
et même si les avis des experts et les
sondages des avis des experts sont loin
d'être fiables
il semble alors déraisonnable de
persister à penser que la question de la
singularité est un sujet qui ne méritent
que la moquerie
même si vous pourrez que ce scénario n'a
que 1 % de chances de se réaliser de
votre vivant ça vaut comme sans doute le
coup d'y penser
l'anr fois on a parlé de chasse ai
demandé qu'est ce qui était un chat on
avait vu dans un réseau de neurones qui
fournissait une réponse à cette question
est dans la vidéo j'avais notamment
critiqué la définition selon lesquelles
les parents d'un chat son achat thibault
au richard fait remarquer que en fait
dans cette définition on utilise le mot
chat à l'intérieur définition du mot
chat et on nous apprend parfois les
colts mais en fait il faut jamais faire
ça en fait c'est pas tout à fait vrai en
fait il existe un cadre défini par
algorithmique notamment où l'on peut
avoir des définitions qu'on appelle
récursive tellement on peut très bien
définir l'ancêtre d'un animal comme
étant soit le père de l'animal soit un
ancêtre du père de l'animal ça c'est une
définition qui est en fait algorithmes
font tout à fait valable et qui en fait
est très souvent utilisée notamment pour
construire des structures de liste dans
des vêtements une liste on va définir ce
serait comme étant soit une liste vide
soit un objet est suivie d'une autre
liste
d'ailleurs ce que j'aime bien avec cet
exemple ce qui montre bien tout
l'intérêt en fait d'un proche ivory smic
pour bien que penser le concept de
définition un blog se demande si pour
entraîner l'intelligence artificielle de
google estime ford on a dit à cet
interstice ya s'il y avait des chats ou
non dans les photos ça c'est le cadre de
ce qu'on appelle l'apprentissage
superviser et en fait l'apprentissage de
superviser ces revers ça existe depuis
bien plus longtemps que 2012 est déjà
des résultats avant mais ce qui est
vraiment stupéfiant avec l'article 2
où l histoire des techs cette ia qui a
découvert le concept de chat c'est
qu'elle a découvertes vraiment tout seul
de juste vous montrer des images et on
lui a demandé de comprendre ces images
de synthétiser de trouver une sémantique
des images et c'est ocde ce qu'on
appelle d'un apprentissage non supervisé
tout ce qu'on fait c'est juste donner
plein d'image alia sans lui dire ce
qu'elle doit faire si sony cherchait à
trouver du sens dans les données
auxquels elle est exposée et
techniquement donner du sens aux images
qui revient vraiment a cherché à trouver
une bonne compréhension de ces images
est en fait il ya un lien très fort
entre l'apprentissage et la compression
puisque si on en croit notamment
l'induction de seconde offre dont j'ai
parlé dans mon livre qui va être publié
d'ailleurs le 7 juin
ça fait déjà un petit peu d'auto coup
dès maintenant vous pouvez d'ailleurs
déjà le précommander sur blessure bref
selon l'induction de solomonoff en fait
l'apprentissage est vraiment de la
compression de données avec perte
jeandel bas pose la question de la
capacité de stockage de notre cerveau
sachant qu'il n'ya finalement que 100
milliards de neurones dans le cerveau
ça laisse suggérer s'il ya un neurone
par concept qu'il n'y a que 100
milliards de concepts qui peuvent être
enregistrées dans notre vie voir ce qui
est pas mal mais qui semble pas tant que
ça en fait ce qu'ils soient c'est que
l'information n'est pas encore des dents
lino rhône mais plutôt dans des
combinaisons d'activation de certains
neurones machine learning
lorsqu'on a un concept en fait ça
correspond vraiment une superposition de
plusieurs activation de plusieurs
neurones qui correspond en fait à un
vecteur ça d'ailleurs qu'on parle de
vecteurs de sémantique tellement dans
world check et si on regarde par contre
l'ensemble des vecteurs qu'on peut pour
composer avec 100 milliards de neurones
là on a plus un nombre qui est de
l'ordre de en fait c'est le nombre de
combinaisons de sous-ensembles en fait
d'activation des neurones parmi 100
maire de nantes qui fait à peu près deux
puissances 100 milliards et la 200
milliards on est vraiment tranquille
c'est beaucoup plus grand que le nombre
de particules de l'univers mais alors
beaucoup beaucoup plus haut que nous les
particulier en hiver je pense que
nicolas m'a bien fait remarquer que dans
l'épisode de 20 heures on a peu parlé
parfois de world check vous avait déjà
parlé du concept de chat et le concept
de chats dans word doc c'est une
représentation sémantique de
d'un mode du mot chat alors que dans
l'épisode 24
c'était la représentation sémantique de
certaines images du coup la question qui
se pose naturellement c'est au savoir ce
qu'on peut pas connectés les 2 et
finalement avoir une même représentation
symantec à la fois pour l'image d'un
chat et pour le texte de chat est en
effet c'est quelque chose qui a été pas
mal étudiés et pas mal fait et notamment
facebook a sorti une application je
crois que c'était il ya deux ans déjà
scellée c'est un truc assez vieux dans
l'histoire du machine learning et c'est
l'application de facebook on peut lui
donner des images étaient capables de
décrire en fait une légende de l'image
espoir est en fait elle devait extraire
la sémantique de l'image puis ré
expliquer cette sémantique à l'aide par
exemple de textes vous pouvez aussi
faire inverse dire du texte et générer
des images hors jeu pas si cet état de
facebook était capable de faire mais
aujourd'hui il ya pas mal de gars qui
sont capables de faire cela et en effet
on a maintenant une répression
sémantique unifiée pour des sens
différents pour des mesures sensorielle
différents et en particulier on peut
avoir des concepts profond qui sont
activés à la fois par l'image d'un chat
ou par le mot chat ce qui est quand même
vraiment vraiment cool et qui commence
vraiment à ressembler à la manière dont
le cerveau fonctionne
monsieur max ils se demandent maintenant
ce qu'il en est de dessins de chat par
exemple peu d'imagés destinées de chasse
que mia est capable de reconnaître qu'il
s'agit d'un chat mais pas d'un rachat
et bien la réponse aujourd'hui c'est
clairement oui d'ailleurs il ya un jeu
avec une autre super vidéo de l'excusé
qui parle de ce jeu qui s'appelle
quickdraw qui est un jeu en fait joué
avec unis rapid schnoering dessiner un
truc est lié à doit deviner ce que c'est
particulier voilà parfois il faut de
dessiner un chalet qu'il ya quoi deviner
qu'il s'agit d'un dessin de chat et là
encore il ya une sémantique qui
correspond pas à l'image brute leur
image ershad certaine manière mais qui
correspond à la sémantique d'une
représentation
deschacht sous forme de dessin et savons
très bien que sesia en fait les
manipulent différentes représentations
du mot chaque ce soit sous la plante
d'image sur la forme de dessins ou lui
sous la forme de textes sont maintenant
elles sont aussi capables de détecter le
bruit d'un chat ou petit à petit elles
sont capables de se doter en fait de
différents sens que tous les sens
petit à petit auquel l'humain a
également accès et en croisant toutes
ces informations en fait elles sont
capables d'avoir des concepts qui sont
indépendants l'origine sensuelle des
données mais plus de quelque chose de
plus fondamental qui est un peu un
variant malgré qu'elles que soient en
fait la forme de mesures censurer des
données qui ont considéré j'espère que
j'avais mais cette vidéo en fait la
question de la singularité c'est une
question assez intéressante mais ce
n'est pas encore la question la plus
fondamentale est plus perçue rang celle
qui va vraiment faire que cette question
est vraiment importante et urgente dès
aujourd'hui en fait la question la plus
fascinante à mon sens c'est la question
de la vitesse de décollage te lire on
parle aussi d'explosion d'un bilan et
c'est ce dont on parlera la prochaine
fois si vous avez aimé cet épisode
français le lac est le commentaire de
partage et pensez à vous abonner épisode
merci au team apollo redon et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois il
faudrait vraiment qu'ils les
probabilités président soit
extraordinairement négligeable pour ce
soit pas un tout petit peu intéressant
de s'intéresser au troisième point le
troisième point c'est vraiment le coeur
du livre de bostrom typiquement est
vraiment le cas de ces réflexions et
voilà la seule raison pour laquelle on
pouvait voir ce serait légitime de dire
ok vraiment on s'en fout ça si c'était
vraiment totalement négligeable si c'est
pas totalement négligeable c'est au
moins intéressant de se pencher sur la
question est effectivement je pense que
justement parce que c'est très difficile
à évaluer
c'est pas négligeable
dire que c'est totalement impossible
séance et faire une prédiction qui est
beaucoup plus précise que toutes les
prédictions phoenix bostrom en fait dire
vraiment ça ne regarde jamais cessé tout
à fait fantaisiste où ça s'est vraiment
faire un pari sur l'avenir qui bien que
d'un certain que paris fait mine boston
symphony lindy jamais autre chose que
ses propos il ya une certaine
probabilité de ceux ci il n'est pas
spécialement optimiste par exemple le
petit pont sur le fait d'arriver à
emilia de niveau humain il est plutôt
pessimiste par rapport en tout cas par
rapport aux chercheurs qui consultent et
île située plutôt dans la tranche des
plus pessimistes
donc voilà donc tout ça pour me mettre
un peu à couvert dire à partir du moment
où vous acceptez que c'est pas
négligeable
les deux premières fortes probabilités
et j'ai l'impression qu'on sait rire
plutôt rationnel de considérer que c'est
pas négligeable
du coup ça devient intéressant qui
s'intéressent à la troisième quand même
même si un peu le risque de passer pour
un fou parce que là c'est envisager
d'aider situation très compliquée